i know you lied
i know you did
you've been lying all along you've been
lying every day of your life do not lie
to me
what is result direction result
direction
is
telling directing the actor by telling
them how you want what effect you want
them to have on the audience
i started out here's my book oh yes
and and this is a re
25th edition yeah this is the
25th anniversary edition of the my
original book directing actors which
came out in 1996
and i the first chapter i started out i
called it result direction and quick
fixes and i started out with a list of
at the time 10 things
that
that i called result direction that
were
ineffective ways to
give direction to actors
and i did it on purpose i did it to get
people's attention
it backfired a little bit because
people would come to my workshops
afterwards and they'd be terrified that
they're going to say the wrong thing
but it's one of the reasons why i was so
thrilled to get the chance to do this
book
and to kind of correct that impression
that
when i talk about result direction it's
it's a quick way to bring up the subject
of subtext
that
that
because what i call the quick fixes
which are the verbs
the facts or emotional history uh
imagery
and physical life and event
um
that that they
they're not always they're not always
that quick they're quick when you know
how to use them
but i but i wanted to have that first
chapter be a way that people
would not lose hope
i wanted them to say okay these are
these are the list of don'ts but there's
you know hope there are things you can
do instead and
but but it did f it did turn out you
know people would come into my workshops
and i say you know i read that list of
things not to do and i do every one of
them and so i'm terrified of saying the
wrong thing now i never wanted people to
be terrified i never wanted people to
think of result direction as the
language police
i always wanted it to be a way to
introduce the idea
that
there's
more to story and more to characters
than just what you see
uh on a on a flat screen that there's uh
there's underneath that the people so
the characters people's emotional
history affects what they do now that
the images in their memory and in their
dreams that that affects what they do
now that the that their their intention
their verb or their intention or their
need or their objective
that's that's where their behavior comes
comes from
and i wanted directors to know more
about that to understand it and not
because they always have to
fix you know tell the actor well don't
play that objective play this one
instead i i i never meant that that's
what i wanted them to do but i wanted
them to understand the tool of objective
of what the character wants what the
character needs
because it's such a helpful way to talk
to actors to ask but to ask them first
what
what
what is your objective
what do you want here
and
so
and also that these tools about subtext
will lead you toward an understanding of
emotional event which is the most
important thing for a director to know
is what is the emotional event of a
scene what is the scene about the
simplest example of result direction is
a line reading
so if a director says to an actor let's
say the line is
uh
don't lie to me
the if
director says you're saying the line
wrong
don't say
don't lie to me say don't lie to me
you know that that's a line reading and
that that's the simple example the
simplest example of of result direction
and i think by now most directors know
they're not supposed to use that
but um
but but it's still it it often gets hard
for them to understand why and if they
don't understand why it's not a good
idea to give line readings or to just to
tell them i want you to be angrier or i
want you to be
sadder
that's another way to give result
direction to say you need to be angrier
and
if they don't understand the why of it
it's easy for them to to feel like oh
gosh i'm going to say something wrong
and i'd better not say anything or and
and
directors in my workshops they used to
come up to me and say well is it okay if
i say this i say well you know it's not
the language police you can say anything
you want
but
ask them what they understand by it
that's that's a helpful way to do it and
ask them what they're working on
create a dialogue with them
so
uh but let me give you an example
of
of how
you know result direction versus
understanding what the emotional event
of a scene is
so
the the scene might be an argument
and
and the uh
and the if the director
says to the actors
this is an argument between best friends
that could result in the end of the
friendship
that creates the emotional stakes
and and and it's very specific
direction of where
this director wants the
the scene to go
and to say something like that instead
of i want you to be angrier
okay
so
that's
that's that's what i that's the real
reason for studying
uh result direction and the alternatives
to it is so that you can get to an
understanding of the emotional event
which is the
which i think the director is
responsible for and should
communicate to the actors
although
side note you should always be ready to
change your mind sometimes a different
emotional event works great or works
better and then you can still move on
even if it's not the one you thought was
going to work
but that's that's kind of the the
difference between
between result directing
you know i want you to get angrier here
i want you to be more disappointed there
versus
talking about the
the the emotional events of the story
that that this
and to think about the differences in
different kinds of arguments so if you
say
this is
instead of saying um this is an argument
between best friends that could result
in the end of the friendship a different
kind of emotional event a different kind
of argument could be
these people argue all the time they
have had the same argument many times
this their their there's they're arguing
this time there's something new about
this argument i want us to find out what
it is
but i'm thinking it is unlikely to lead
to the end of the friendship
now i also use the terms of saying it's
unlikely to or it could instead of it
will lead to the end of the relation
friendship or won't lead to the end of
the friendship so that whatever does
happen whatever emotional event does
happen
happens in the moment
while the camera is running
so that it's not all
uh
oh
you know expect expected it's it's not
all
pat and
sort of paint by the numbers
so if i were in a scene and i'm an actor
and i'm delivering a line very flat and
it's don't lie to me so you're the
director
you you're saying um with result
direction
and
using that it would be to correct me on
my tone maybe but if you came at it from
another angle you'd be explaining
why i'm saying this line
and through that i would know how to put
more emotion to it
well
it might be or
a real quick
verb i might say what's your intention
on this line
okay so then i'm saying well this is a
friendship
and
she doesn't understand me and
i've told her repeatedly don't lie to me
i would say let that come into the line
because that sounds very good to me what
you just said sounds like a very good
way to play it so i'd say let that come
into the line i think that would give it
would give it more spark obviously so
the way you said it first right so i'm
developing it so yeah yeah
but
but uh
let me talk to talk about action verbs a
little bit active verbs
uh
because if you uh
i i did think of an example to do this
um if the if the line is don't lie to me
um
i thought of three different intentions
that we could have it could be i'm going
to pick too convinced to
accuse
and to beg
very different from each other right so
just to give you an example of how that
would be
i i'll do a little
a little improvisation
of convincing you
of of something
and
the kind of the the subtext
underneath convincing is telling
somebody what you think they should do
so so i'm gonna say
you know
i think you should never lie
i don't think
you or anybody else
should ever lie
don't lie to me
okay
so that would be to convince if it's
accused then it's
i know you lied
i know you did
you've been lying all along you've been
lying every day of your life do not lie
to me
okay oh or if it's bae then it's
i don't know what i'm gonna do
if nobody will tell me the truth i need
i need to be told the truth don't lie to
me
okay so it comes out different
and there could be different reasons as
you were asking you know talking about
the reasons why a person might be
begging or a person might be accused and
accusing or a person might be convincing
but of course sometimes
sometimes characters do
the wrong thing
sometimes they want somebody to
be open and honest with them but they do
the wrong thing to get it if they demand
that they be honest
might not work right
so um
so
the verbs can be you know you can play
opposites you can
do
lots of things with them but there is
always a reason for them